I don't know is anyone gonna buy it I
mean do I look pregnant I mean
yes I can see it smash
[Music]
still sound like an angel you sure thank
God you were the airport
I know you wouldn't let your best friend
die I'm still gonna arrest you I just
can't do that if you're dead whatever
you got to tell yourself baby steps it's
hard getting them out of his shell tell
me about it every time we get emotional
he's like noise smart okay can we focus
up here we still don't know what your
Hitman looks like so we're gonna have to
flush him out wait a minute where did
the toilets on this boat go you don't
want to know
ocean oh that's even worse that's where
my shrimp live anyways they'll probably
try to hit me at my show this afternoon
we saw that doing what I love
getting people horny at Sea yeah yeah
that's gross all right here's the plan
we're gonna leave you alone on stage and
dangle you as bait damn bait
down before you
eat all right I trust you
but if you're going to blend in
you got to blend in if you like
[Music]
two are looking good really kind of feel
like I'm Jimmy Buffett's tennis coach no
it's working you know I had a major
crush on Magnum PI major oh should I
grow a mustache yeah you should actually
I can't I'm physically incapable I
shouldn't have suggested that should we
go in
hey Gina we got an anonymous gift basket
yeah it's full of treats it's got Meats
cheeses candies all the food groups
cheese is amazing it melts in my mouth
and in my hands French chocolates French
cheeses tiny French pickles did none of
you detectives think this might be a
gift for Captain Hook from someone in
France like his husband poor example
what
no way this is a nice present from an
unknown appreciative citizen that wanted
us to munch what's this then
dear Captain Raymond Holt thinking of
you best Dr Kevin Costner PhD he even
used their pet names oh no I ate the
chocolate covered strawberry that's the
most intimate snack of them all hold's
gonna be back from his meeting in 30
minutes what do we do eat the no no
no
it's okay
we can fix this
check it out sir a lovely gift basket
that Kevin sent you all the way from
Paris straight from Paris
stapler
scissors
rubber bands
that man really knows me
amazingly wearing holds clothes is our
best option everyone
prepare to enter High Society
[Applause]
okay how's everybody feeling anyone else
have the weird urge to lecture
themselves Peralta what are you doing
brother what are you doing
I conjured him
Captain Holt what a pleasant surprise
Gina told me that you were delayed due
to a wire situation yes the situation is
you can rip them all out but the car
still works sorry boo
wait why is the whole Squad here why is
everyone wearing my clothes
my God
you lost chatter
so here it is
[Music]
I really hope you like it but if you
don't I will kill myself Charles it
looks amazing it's beautiful how can I
ever repay you get pregnant use your
body to give the world more Jake holy
crap all right I'm gonna take Charles
away from you now I will see you up
there
Amy we're go
hey Malibu knows I don't know you
okay
[Music]
the whole thing no no not the whole
thing okay
doesn't matter how much humping I do
he's still not getting it
then this is happening
hey Karen can I talk to you for a second
in private I'm a little plugged up
oh well say no more I have an entire
cabinet devoted just to that I don't
know is anyone gonna buy it I mean do I
look pregnant I mean
I guess I can see it I think it's
amazing oh Jake and Amy and baby makes
three I don't know if I believe in God
but I have prayed for this that is
psychotic all right Ames let's go over
your cover story again okay my name is
Isabel Cortez I'm in for murder because
some perv on the subway tried to touch
me and I was like did someone order
tracheotomy okay I think that's a little
too technical we need to work on your
tough talk so what are you in for Cortez
none of your damn business nice keep
going keep going I'm gonna split you
like a Sunday with Grandpa okay
and the part was great yeah
although mean threats generally don't
involve having desserts with your
grandparents so just try again keep
telling me what to do and I'll stab your
face off oh yes like that okay now
here's the plan instead of you
approaching Mara we're gonna get her to
come to you yeah try and spread the word
that you've got to connect on the
outside that gives you access to
contraband cigarettes burner phones
pornography Emmy women don't watch
they do oh yeah oh wow yeah well that's
an exciting Revelation for me huh
Charles what took so long I want to get
out of this Zoo before we take off we're
not going anywhere the flight is booked
and there's already a huge standby line
what we have to get on that plane were
you Stern Amy you know I wasn't
I've got this Holt's in danger and that
lady's in my way
never get between a teacher's pet and a
teacher
okay best lady I don't care what you
have to do today oh you sweet thing
you're pregnant
So Pregnant what a miracle right please
give me special treatment hey what's the
update from OEM about the power coming
back on yeah they're working on it so
listen I've been timing your
contractions what ow I've been hiding
them so well no you have not there's too
much radio chatter let's try to keep
non-emergency Communications down to it
[Music]
minimum they're happening every five
minutes and they're lasting 20 seconds
your baby's coming it's still not active
labor don't worry I'm not gonna have the
baby here and get placenta all over your
desk or whatever it is that you're
afraid of but we'll send us something
that can get all over actually
technically you know what don't answer
that I don't want to know I promise I
will go to the hospital as soon as
let me just make the noise enough won't
let anybody
[Music]
wondering how he'd like to be introduced
um nope I haven't seen him cheddar I
have a bad feeling about this cheddar is
up to something come on
[Music]
oh no get her oh hi Kevin we found
cheddar oh my God Raymond is on a case
foreign
[Music]